we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p let's take a
listen to this voicemail hey guys listen
i like to confront trump supporters and
get them going here at work but they're
already too stupid but my boss is
relatively the smartest one so I go to
him and I show him a Sally Yates James
Comey Russia give me an excuse right and
my boss says they're all crooked every
politician is crooked
everyone in DC is crooked none would
ever care so when educated Trump voter
finally realizes they're totally effed
and they voted for the wrong person
and they know he's crooked their answer
is they're all crooked Hillary's crooked
everyone's corporate Republicans
Democrats you guys come across this or
what people they get they know they're
in a corner and they just everyone's bad
oh yeah some they're all the same nobody
cares what a college there's an
institute over yeah the eggman they're
checking in total cognitive dissonance
which is you talk about how great a
politician is soon as they do something
bad you say well they all do it this is
what's called the de feasibility test
which is well ok you like this
politician what would make you change
your mind about them oh if they did
something bad when they do that bad
thing they'd say well my mind hasn't
been changed because every politician
does this and they're a politician after
all it's a logical fallacy and I think
that argument is going to be acceptable
to some people when it comes to any
other politician but the whole appeal
behind Donald Trump was that he wasn't a
politician and you know he berated
everyone else we all talk no action he
was supposed to be the champion for
changing the system right if at any
point you fall back on well all
politicians do whatever it is Trump is
doing you been great part voted for him
because he wasn't going to be like every
other politician so it's a direct
contradiction to a campaign promise that
at least influenced you partially
yeah I feel for the eggman and
fortunately I don't have that many
conversations like that in my in my
regular life yeah I mean that's pretty
combative there yeah I guess that you
you involved in conversations like that
but frequency not what's not with too
much frequency that's good yeah I
recommend avoiding them because it's
pretty toxic on the bonus show today the
French just like Donald Trump even more
than
dislike vladimir putin the chinese
president and the german chancellor a
fist fight erupted on a Southwest
Airlines flight I'm going to go into a
little bit of detail Pat about my
experiences with Southwest Airlines and
fistfights and fist fights as well sure
also Amazon is building a large building
in Seattle half of that building is
going to be turned into a homeless
shelter administered by a local charity
that runs a series of shelters is it a
great thing is it just an attempt to get
positive PR is it both is it neither I
think those are the four possible
combinations yes we will discuss these
stories and more on today's bonus show
you can sign up and get instant access
to the members only bonus show by
becoming a member at david pakman.com
slash membership and of course you can
also become a patron at patreon.com
forward slash david pakman show speak to
you on the bonus show don't miss it